[Musique]
je
ça dépend de quel point de vue on se
place et de la situation des parts
autoritaire ci s'est imposée par le
gouvernement peut-être après
effectivement parfois le gouvernement
doit répondre à des situations assez
extraordinaire donc c'était le cas de la
première vague autoritaire c'est parce
que c'est un plutôt un jugement que
qu'autre chose qui va être personnel moi
j'ai tendance à penser que c'est basé
malgré tout sur des situations
extraordinaires donc pas d'un serment
autorités en ce soir en france on parle
de confinement autoritaire en effet 1 0
il a été décidé sans contre-pouvoir dans
un conseil de défense qui n'était pas
transparent qui me fait l'objet de
débats dans le cadre d'une mise en pause
de la constitution dans la mesure où il
ya un état d'urgence
donc en france il est clairement
autoritaire en suède le confinement est
beaucoup plus volontaire dans la mesure
où les suédoises respecter des
recommandations de l'agencé nationale
[Musique]
parce que ça dépend beaucoup du contexte
va parler pendant l'émission des
chiffres sur les français qui assez
réticents à la vaccination pour un croco
vide je pense qu'il faut en priorité
vaccinés qui sont à risque qui en auront
besoin qui sont au contact des malades
et pour le reste évalué la situation
il aurait tendance à préférer que ce
soit obligatoire la situation au plus
vite mais c'est sion politique un peu
complexe je pense je pense qu'il ne faut
jamais essayé de faire le bien la place
des gens par contre le vaccin il faut le
recommander c'est typiquement le genre
de médicaments ou de solutions dont les
bénéfices sont largement supérieurs aux
risques et aux populations se peut que
nous recommander de novak signer dans la
mesure où le vaccin est efficace va lui
procurer une immunité collective à ceux
qui ne peuvent pas vaccinés notammant
les personnes âgées ou celles qui
s'offre aux deux orbites
essayez potentiellement de faire
comprendre aux citoyens qu'on n'a pas
envie de les confiner ex pas un objectif
en soi qu'il faut au maximum
évitez soi même les déplacements les
sorties etc
le plus possible le plus longtemps
possible et peut-être j'espère mettre en
place d'aidés confinement plus
géographiquement ciblées en temps un peu
plus limité pour 4 limiter un peu la
casse et éviter que les citoyens soient
si mécontent au final et éviter
évidemment l'impact économique et sur la
santé mentale
je pense qu'il va falloir maintenant
qu'on a beaucoup de recul
cela faisait beaucoup plus sur le choix
des individus dans la mesure où les deux
premières vagues et les confinements
autoritaire les deux premières vagues
nous ont coûté très cher et que ça va
être très difficile de maintenir ce
rythme là d'un point de vue économique
les drames de des premiers confinement
sont aussi des drames en termes de
pauvreté qui y jouent aussi un rôle sur
sur la santé et dans cette mesure je
pense qu'il va falloir les prochains
confinant les bases et beaucoup plus sur
des recommandations à suivre par les
individus en étant beaucoup beaucoup
moins coercitif
[Musique]
je